the hours in between four and six are
the time of least distraction in this
age of dramatic interruption you do any
new habit and practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive in the place of
automaticity
all changes hard at first messy in the
middle and it's gorgeous at the end
wanna be happy build a life not just the
business hey it's Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back and lack a belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you to you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn a
simple morning routine that will change
your life also if you want to have more
confidence check out by 2:54 series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below stop resisting I
encourage you stop resisting the natural
flow of epic performance stop resisting
the natural seasons of life one of the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us is because we are afraid of
being judged and so to become fearless
why not find some time every day to
practice becoming fearless there's a
reason why the visionary founder of
Starbucks Howard Schultz rises before
the Sun there's a reason why Michelle
Obama rice very early there's a reason
why Tim Cook
eating Apple gets up before the dawn
first of all the hours between 4 & 6 are
the time of least distraction in this
age of dramatic interruption number 2
the hours before the Sun rises is the
period where your brain is most
available to your primary creativity so
while you're sleeping your brain
actually washes itself but also it lets
them go the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available to
access your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why I
encourage you to get a brilliant might
say Robin while I'm not an early riser I
can't put mine over mattress I can't win
the Battle of the bed grand my never
gone up early
dad couldn't get up early I guess I'm
not the kind of person who can rise
before the Sun and what I would suggest
to you is simply this
what science confirms in particular the
data of University College London you do
any new habit and practice it for 66
days and you will arrive in place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not 266
days of rising at 5:00 a.m. will get you
to a place where it's easier to get up
at 5:00 and then not to get up at 5:00
a.m. you'll reach a place of
automaticity
in my book the five am club i say all
change is hard at first and it's messy
in the middle and it's gorgeous
at the end I'll repeat that again
because it's so important all change is
hard at first
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end in the book there's a chapter on
the hobbit installation process that
actually explains the three phases every
habit goes through before you wire it
into the place where it's automatic
number one destruction
number two integration and number three
and
imitation really important to remember
them so you can get up early you can
install habits as a matter of fact
neuroplasticity is just the fun dominant
that speaks to the fact the brain is
like a muscle the more you flex it and
push it the more it's gonna grow you
have that gift it's not just for Federer
and Serena Williams and Oprah Winfrey
and Shakespeare and Joe Michele Basquiat
and Steve Jobs and Elon Musk you have a
brain that has the capability to grow
and adapt what is the 20-20-20 formula
that lies at the core of the 5 a.m. Club
method well the first 20 minutes move
sweat you'll release BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor which will increase
the neural connections of your brain as
well as a repair brain cells damaged by
stress and also promote neurogenesis
which is the formation of new brain
cells I know this is a lot of
information but I want to give you great
content in this video
exercising for 20 minutes first thing in
the morning from 5:00 to 5:20 the first
part of the 20-20-20 formula releases
dopamine which is the inspirational
neurotransmitter how valuable is that
for your creativity productivity for the
rest of the day
cortisol the fear hormone is highest
first thing in the morning exercising
will reduce it serotonin is released so
you'll feel happier now it's 5:20 you're
full of energy you've optimized your
cognition your focus is increasing
it's only 5:20 the rest of the world is
asleep just imagine that advantage you
already have second pocket for the
20-20-20 formula is all about reflection
we live in a world where people don't
reflect anymore a lot of people are busy
being busy what's the point of being
busy around the wrong things so for 20
minutes from 520 to 540 you reflect you
pray or write in a journal meditate you
can visualize you can script out a
blueprint for a great day ahead which
habit researchers call a pre commitment
strategy which actually increases your
real power in your ability to get your
most important priorities done okay now
it's 5:40 from 5:40 to 6 o'clock this is
the final 20 minute pocket of the
20-20-20 formula
the first pocket was about moved the
second is reflective the third is grow
of coached billionaires and CEOs and NBA
superstars and members of royalty for
over 20 years here's what I realized
when I work with the best of the best
they love to learn they
to grow they don't see investing in
yourself or investing in your skills or
investing in your growth a cost they
think about the value received I call it
the 2 X 3 X mindset to double your
income and your impact triple your
investment in two core areas your
personal mastery and your professional
capability so for 20 minutes what do you
do you listen to a podcast to review
your journal notes you read a book you
watch a valuable video you just do
something you read an autobiography you
do something to grow your capacities and
materialize more of the potential you
have been born into and now at 6 o'clock
Steve optimized your mindset you have
purified your heart set you've
calibrated your health set you escalated
your soul set you feel fundamentally
different in the 5 M Club there's
another model called the 4 habits of
history makers and one of the elements
is day stacking the whole idea simply
does get your morning's right your days
are going to be fundamentally more
energetic creative productive and
high-impact and a great week is nothing
more than a series of great days and a
great month is the same thing and a
great quarter is just a series of well
lived weeks and it just can
continues and it creates this upward
spiral of success just by getting from 5
a.m. to 6 a.m.
your victory hour to world class every
morning consistency really is the mother
of mastery and on your morning you're
really going to elevate your life now I
have a special bonus clip from Robert on
how to aim for legendary that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question today I want to know what did
you think of this video should we do
more of these kind of standalone topics
from one person on one topic if you
liked it let me know if you hated it and
never want to see it again let me now
put it down the comments below
and if you made it this far in the video
I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe in the comments as well
nothing fails like success you're
successful maybe it's in your health
maybe it's in your finances maybe it's
in your career maybe it's in your family
life maybe it's in the way that you show
up in the world awesome you're in a
really vulnerable place right now it is
one thing to be successful it is another
thing to sustain success over the coming
decades is that it not a powerful idea I
mean let's go to the entertainment
industry it's very hard to be a one-hit
wonder let's not knock a one-hit wonder
but it's even harder to become an iconic
rock band or hip hop band let's go to
the Arts it is very hard to come up with
your Sistine Chapel got it it is even
harder to become a Michelangelo so are
you playing the short game or are you
playing the long game this is rule
number two you know or lesson number two
the life has taught me play the long
game aim for legendary don't just say
I'm gonna be world-class in my diamond
pursuit for a little window of time say
I want to have the guts and the grit and
the occupant and the mindset and the
capability and the commitment to create
enduring success and that's why I say
nothing fails like success you look at
the restaurant that is hot in your
neighborhood right now they're on the
path to obsolescence if they're not
really careful sure they went from a
little neighborhood shop that made
beautiful pasta that had
great service that had the owner on the
floor shaking your hand getting to know
your name
then they got written up in the
magazines and they then they got
interviewed and then word of mouth
spread like wildfire and what happened
they became arrogant you see success can
be so toxic and it happens it is such a
pull on every human being it just plays
with your mind and you literally shift
from humility to arrogance you shift
from humility to arrogance and once the
arrogance sets in in a mindset it starts
to populate every other person on the
team every other person in the culture
every other person in the community and
it is a very short fall from success to
irrelevance so lesson number two is
nothing fails like success as you become
more successful become more humble as
you become more successful work even
harder as you become more successful
care even more about your product as you
become more successful learn even more
I invite you it when you are the the
Titan of your industry be sitting in the
room with 18 year olds beginning their
game when you are the the icon of your
field be the person who is up not a five
o'clock anymore let's play at four
o'clock reading listening to the podcast
writing in your journal setting your
goals focusing on your intentions as you
become more successful be more humble as
you become more successful be even more
punctual as you become more successful
become even more passionate as you
become older become even younger
yesterday I was walking on the street
and I met this man in his eighties he
said Rob and I finally retired he's
probably close to 90 and he is a
legendary clothier in the country that I
live in and he just retired and he
started his shop which is now an empire
in 1954 so I don't know what that is but
that is decades and decades and decades
and decades and he did not want to
retire he just retired but he is still
on fire to do amazing things
age is just a number do not let an old
person into your body nothing fails like
success
if you
to learn the three simple steps to
building discipline check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there there are some actually
key is that very very disciplined people
have and here is the most important one
and this would change your life